- I do believe that we
need to reframe success.
We have to, for the fucking sake
of so many fucking millions of people,
we have to make success happiness.
We have to, have to, have to, have to.
- Hey everybody, this is David Neagle
and welcome to the
Successful Mind Podcast.
Today, we are in New York at VaynerMedia
and we have our special
guest Gary Vaynerchuk.
Gary, thank you so much for doing this.
- Really excited to be here.
- I'm very excited to
talk to you about this
because you talk about
something as self awareness.
You say that self awareness is the key.
And my number one question for you
is how did you become self aware?
When did that happen for you?
When did it all click in?
You're like this is who I am,
this is what I'm here to do
and then you were like nose
to the grindstone with it?
- In some way when I hear that question
what feels natural to me
is an evolution between 11 and 18.
Somewhere between definitely fourth grade
when I had the conviction and the guts
to have weird little
conversations with myself in bed
when I would be anxious
about the fact that I was
making this transition
to being a bad student.
I don't know how else to say it.
In third grade, I got straight A's
and would win in flash cards
'cause I have good math skills
and in fourth grade, I literally
started getting bad grades
and A, it didn't come
natural to me anymore.
Now I think my mind
was wandering in class.
So the ability to just
listen and go off of that
to be successful became a problem
because now I was
already starting to think
about how to sell baseball
cards to my friends,
what am I gonna do after school,
let me make a joke to
make everybody laugh,
my brain started to wander
and then it was also around the time
when it was time to actually
do stuff at home, like homework,
and that was unacceptable
'cause I had to play Nerf football
and try to sell and video games.
So between that moment
and even right up to
senior year of high school
navigating that and understanding
this is what I'm good at,
this is what I'm not good at,
and then really in high school
intuitively, subconsciously, naturally,
being able to not have to fit in
and not being affected by,
look, it's really interesting,
I think anybody who's listening,
maybe this is Jersey thing
but everybody made fun of
everybody all the time always.
That was just the nature of, right?
I think a lot about what
are we doing to children
in our parenting now
that make it so difficult?
And extreme bullying is very different
than getting made fun of occasionally
and so there's a lot of variables to this
but the high school years of like
not worrying about my
popularity and valuing,
one of the things that I'm most proud of
is getting DM's and messages
from high school friends today
saying, man, this is so cool
'cause this was always actually you.
You literally have the, verbatim,
you had the guts
to be friends with
everybody in high school.
And I was very proud of that.
I was very proud of
weirdest kid on the bus.
- So you didn't try to fit in?
- I thought fitting in was
fitting in with everybody
instead of fitting in to like six people.
So I wanted to fit in with the kid
that nobody was nice to,
I wanted to fit in to the kids
that were naturally
kind of my core friends
who were like into sports or sports cards.
I wanted to fit in with popular kids,
and that was easy too,
I am who I am,
obviously, I have people skills
but I was aware that it was unusual
how I was navigating through high school,
not going to parties, but working,
being friends with the weird kids,
not overpandering to the
coolest kids in our school,
not being good at grades.
I was an enigma my whole life
and I think 11 to 18
was when that manifested
and that's a long-winded answer to
that's when I started understanding myself
which is what I would
argue self awareness was.
It was also when I went through
wait a minute, I'm not
the cutest kid in class,
wait a minute, I'm not the best athlete
because in second and fourth, fifth grade,
in fourth grade, I thought
I was the best looking,
most athletic kid in my class
and very honestly I think
there's a chance I was but, but--
- But that's because also because your mom
was pumping you up,
like she was like positive all the way.
- Yes, that and I was competitive
and I have great hand eye coordination
and I matured slowly
so I had boyish looks.
Yes, all those things but it was a great,
I was not scared of all the bad stuff
and I think we live in a world right now
where people are scared of the bad stuff.
- [David] Tremendously.
- And I believe that that's
what leads to delusion.
You don't want to face that
you're not the fastest,
you're not the best looking,
you're not the smartest.
You don't want to face that.
You don't want to accept that
which leads to a lack of self awareness.
- So I'm kind of guessing
that you were sensitive kid.
I hear you cried a lot,
you got your feelings hurt?
- By the way, I'm gonna
give you a huge dap,
that is the first time
that somebody has said that
and it couldn't be more true.
I cried constantly from 1982 to 1988
and I mean multiple times
a week, real crying.
- So that brings me to another question.
So you talked about when you
went to work with your dad
and he kind of sensed your bullshit right,
like you could really bullshit people
and you made a comment
on one of your podcasts
that there were many times
you were in his office crying.
- Yes.
- What was he doing?
- You know what's funny,
him saying to me like,
the number's the number,
my dad doesn't talk a lot,
so he was a man from the old school.
So it wasn't like he sat me down and said,
son, this embellishing
or lying is unacceptable,
it wasn't like that,
it would be like a customer would walk in
and I would trey to sell
them a bottle of wine,
and you want to talk about
not being self aware,
the audacity that I had as a
14-year-old who looked nine
to have a grownup come
into a liquor store,
hand them the bottle of wine
that I knew we had to sell
and be like you should buy this,
and they would look at me and say,
well, have you had it?
And I would say yes with
a straight fucking face
and really like believed it
is pretty ludicrous
and what would happen is
he would give me a look
and I could sense like oh I
did something wrong, not right
even though I accomplished the goal.
And very quickly it started chipping away.
The reason I would cry
is my dad is tough.
I would be a 15-year-old kid,
I would work 11 hours,
like we'd leave the house at seven a.m.,
the store, got there at 8:10,
my dad would do the deposit,
I'd have to keep myself busy,
the store opened at nine,
it's now seven p.m.,
no lunch break, I've worked very minute,
this is like child fucking
hardcore real labor
and then at 6:50 I would go to my dad
and muster up the guts to be like,
hey dad, are we going home soon?
And he would like bark at me.
And that made me cry, I don't know,
it was like sad, I was like
fucking like fuck, this is hard.
And the truth is actually
I'm embellishing a little bit there,
not that that, that would upset me,
what made me cry actually
is my dad genuinely did
not treat employees well,
and I'm sensitive to it as
I'm saying it right now.
He transformed in the way that
he changed my ability to lie
I changed his point of view on employees.
He just wasn't nice.
I'd watch people really work.
He came from the Soviet Union.
He looked at employees like not the way,
genuinely the complete opposite
of the way I look at employees.
I look at them
and I just know what I feel
and I feel a sense of responsibility
and my dad genuinely
felt like I'm paying you
and fucking work, like
fuck you, like really
and that really bothered me.
- Yeah, well the guy was
working for his fucking life.
What a break to get
out of the Soviet Union
and be able to come
here and do what he did.
- I judged him immensely at the time.
Look, there's people that
have come from hard places
that don't treat their
employees like shit.
So I still judge it at some level.
I understand it a lot more.
He really feared, really feared,
was crippled by the notion
of people stealing from him, crippled.
- Did that happen a lot
in the Soviet Union?
Was that was the deal?
- Oh, so I don't know if you know this.
This is one of the most fascinating things
to talk to Americans about.
I don't think Americans
actually really genuinely
understand socialism or communism.
- Agree.
- 'Cause they can't, I don't blame.
- Everything was stolen.
- [David] Everything was stolen.
- The government owns everything.
So imagine every store and every company
is owned by the government.
So I Gary, don't own Vayner,
I'm some general manager of,
not compensated in any
way based on its success.
So now I'm making a deal with Dustin
that he can come in at night
and steal the computers and
sell 'em on the black market
but kick me some cash,
everything was stolen.
The entire country ran
on the black market.
Think about what's illegal in America,
drugs, black market,
guns at some level, a certain type,
but everything that's illegal
here is on the black market.
- And everything is over there.
- Everything, milk and
tile and carpet and chairs.
People waited 13 years,
my parents waited 13 years to get a phone
and 20 years to get the
line for a refrigerator
and 15 for a car
and you waited seven
hours in line for bread.
When I talk about utter ridiculousness
of entitlement in America
in its current state,
seven dollar coffees,
complaining about Delta
being late by 10 minutes,
I not only come from a kid
that grew up in America
in a very immigrant household
that never bought anything
for anybody about anything,
I also come as the byproduct of parents
and stories my entire childhood
of ludicrous shit
that not a person here can understand,
not here in this room,
not anybody who's listening.
Go wait seven hours in
line for a piece of bread
and have access to no other food.
Go, show me, show me how
much you're gonna cry
about not getting as many
likes on Instagram posts.
- There's this huge
breeding of entitlement
that is going on in the country that is--
- It's called prosperity.
It's why empires fall,
Rome did it, Genghis Kahn
did it, we're doing it.
We are gonna lose.
China already won.
This is just watching it play out.
This is over.
Every little Chinese kid
is way more hungrier
than our little fuckers.
And guess what, I say good.
I don't want it to be, this is my team,
this is the jersey I'm wearing--
- Do you think we rebound from it?
- No, Europe hasn't rebounded from it.
We beat the fuck out of them.
No, there's no rebounding
'cause it's the progression of the game.
The young, hungrier thing wins
and the fatter, older thing loses.
We're the fatter, older thing.
We think somebody owes us shit.
For what?
Why?
I love it.
I love losing.
I love the process.
I love merit, that's why I love losing.
I do believe that one kid
in the suburb of China
who is a single child
because of population control
and has parents driving the
shit out of them to make it,
and of course that has all
its own shortcomings too,
we all know what our
grandparents did to our parents,
I get it,
the question is which one's better?
We're very good
at sitting in our collective
ivory towers in America
judging our parent's generation
and it was tough and beating a kid
and hitting and all this,
haahahahah, guess what?
We're about to fucking lose.
- They don't think that they can.
- What's worse, spanking your kid
or creating such delusion
that they're depressed for the
rest of their fucking life?
I don't know.
I'm gonna hit a kid instead.
And of course, everything's a balance
but like there's a balance
between beating the fuck
out of your child for real,
like extreme terrible things
that happening our society
and what my mom did
which was smack me in the
face when I got out of hand,
which said fuck, I'm
not gonna do that again,
I don't want to get punched again.
And it wasn't punched,
it was an open hand slap
but it fucking hurt.
- Where did your mom's
positivity come from?
- Her natural DNA.
She lost her mother at five,
her dad went to jail when
she was eight for 10 years.
She fucking lived in the Soviet Union.
It definitely didn't come
from her environment.
- That's interesting.
Well, like you were saying before,
there's a lot of people
that grew up in different environments
but their attitude, how that
plays out in their life--
- By the way, for the record,
and I love cosigning my parents,
perfectly parented, all that shit,
and my mom crushed it all time,
I've mentioned it eight billion times,
I promise you with the
natural DNA that I was given
if I was born under a fucking rock
in like fucking a shitty town in Turkey,
to like some shit, shit, shit,
I'd fucking be here,
probably with a little
bit more fucked up shit
and a little bit less love to give
but I'd be here
'cause I'm optimistic.
- Here's one of the things that I find
that's really interesting,
you talk about you have this natural DNA,
that your success is
wrapped up in your DNA
and one of the things that I do
is I help people
that want to become
successful, really successful.
So we work on their mindset,
we help them build out the company
that they're building, whatever,
but what's fascinating about it
is you can't instill the
want in a person to do it.
So you have people be like,
hey, I want to do this
and then they don't do anything
and then you have other individuals
they want it and they'll do
anything that is necessary
to get there.
- There's a huge division
between people that want for stuff
and people who want for process.
- Totally.
- And I think one of the
things I'm trying to figure out
is in the framework that you set that up,
this is why I want to change success.
You're, properly, because
of the way we all came up,
you're creating a system, I assume,
I'm making some assumptions here,
that a level of, the framework
creates success financially,
'cause that's the nature of a business.
I believe that there's a real atomic bomb
that I can drop on society
over the next 50 years
around actually reframing success,
which will then lead to
everybody having the chance
to love a process.
There's a lot of people
who have the natural DNA to be
an all-time stay-at-home dad
but because we haven't
created the framework yet
to making a stay-at-home dad
who crushes and raised three children
that go on to do incredible things
as an incredible north
star of being successful
in the same way that we do a
billionaire or an NBA champion
or a rapper that wins a Grammy,
we have not given macro permission yet
for the people to self,
I know employees right
now that work for me, men,
and I know their wives
that they should be doing reversal,
that the man should stay at
home and do the nurturing
and the mom's the fucking shark
and she's not happy and he's not happy
and the only reason they're doing it
is we have not had
a mature enough
conversation around success.
We have created so many,
by the way, we talk, thank God,
we talk so much more now
about women and minorities
and that thing but like a guy
who deep in his soul
thinks he's a nurturing father
and wants to stay home
is frowned upon by his
contemporaries, friends and society
immediately it goes into
old school people thinking,
he's a loser and he can't provide
and he's balking out
yet he would love that process.
There are absolutely people
who do not love the process
of building a business that makes money.
And thus, they will stop and start
and have micro wins and macro failures
and will never achieve it.
- If a person comes to us
and they want to work with us,
that's one of the first
questions that we ask them,
is it actually love the
process of what they do?
Because if they don't, they'll fail.
If they're just going after
the car or their house
or the jet or whatever it is,
it's like, no, it won't
happen, you will fail.
- And I think eventually
they'll be more businesses built
on bailing them out,
I have to be empathetic to what you have,
up front opportunity
costs and other things,
it think there's a lot of
good stuff on the horizon.
I genuinely believe your business,
you exact human beings 40 years from now
as things get reframed,
the business was built from day one
to be able to afford to
kick Dustin out a week in
when you just decided no way,
whereas I'm just, and
maybe that is what you do
but I would never expect
a business to do that.
I do believe that we
need to reframe success.
We have to make happiness,
we have to, for the fucking sake
of so many fucking millions of people,
we have to make success happiness.
We have to, have to, have to, have to,
we have to teach people
how to live very happily
making $81,000 a year,
that is controlling their expenses,
that is not applying for credit cards,
that is not valuing the clothes they wear
and the cars they drive.
We have to teach parents
how to make their
children feel comfortable
that they have a worse car or things.
We have to teach that as an advantage.
Kids are funny,
I think you can educate kids
at seven or eight of like,
hey, we have less,
that is going to be your advantage.
I believed it
and so others can too.
We've just become very consumeristic,
we've become very at the mercy of opinion,
judgment is at an all-time high.
People are just judging
people left and right now
because of the political climate.
- And they're crashing because of it.
- Oh, I don't think we've
even seen the crash.
We are in a opioid and
mental health crisis
and the economy is phenomenal.
Does everybody understand
what's about to happen next?
Do you understand that
only financial success
is holding up many as a last leg
and when that goes, the whole,
I genuinely believe the mental carnage
that comes with the next economic downturn
is going to be far more
extreme than we can predict
because the overlay of
depression is far greater
than it was in 1987, in 1998,
excuse me in 2008, in 2001 post-9/11,
and the dot-com bubble
and all the other times it's happened.
I'm very, very, very concerned
and hence my actions speak to that.
My content has taken a fundamental shift
over the last two to three years
because I want to put
my head on the pillow
when this all goes down to say,
I gave it my best at-bat.
Very few people on Earth
have spent the dollars and time
to create a communication infrastructure
to pump positivity with
practicality at scale
to the level that I have on fucking Earth.
- I don't know anybody.
- And so I need to do that
because I believe I see
what's about to happen
and I can't look the other way
and look myself in the mirror
when it actually goes down
when I know I have it in me
to be the kind of communicator
that can make a positive impact.
And by the way, I actually
said this yesterday
to Phil Toronto over dinner,
my friend and business associate,
I said, huh, I had never thought about it,
and this is probably why I
just said what I just said
'cause how the subconscious works,
I have a funny feeling
that Gary Vee consumers,
people that consume my content,
are gonna be major winners
during the next downturn
because they're going
to believe, like I do,
that this adversity is good,
they're going to enjoy going back to Rocky
and moving in with their
parents and all this,
they're going to put the process
of the rebuilding on a pedestal
while the far majority
that haven't consumed this perspective
are gonna think it's the worst
thing that ever happened.
- Well it's 'cause it's
built on a false narrative.
They blew something that's
absolutely not true,
that's never gonna go away.
- I agree.
- Okay, we have a question,
so we're giving away
a case of Empathy Wine
to one of our listeners.
Her name is Chef Lizette and this is--
- I've heard of Chef Lizette
who has interacted with
every single content of mine
over the last eight years.
- Well maybe you've heard this before.
So she said, "You stated so
smartly on a sports podcast
"with Adam Shine
"that you believe the metrics
"for vetting incoming football players
"should be based more on
emotional intelligence
"versus bench press or performance stats.
"What should the metrics or standards be
"for putting social media
influencers on a pedestal?"
- What was the transition she just made?
- "What should the
metrics be, or standards,
"for putting social media
influencers on a pedestal?"
- Well it definitely should
not be following count,
and that is what we currently score on.
I think where Chef
Lizette is going properly
is I believe in the gray,
not in the black and white,
and the point I was making
on Shine's podcast was
now that I've been in the
football business for three years,
I'm like, whoa, right,
maybe 'cause football
is my one weird place,
I never deployed my thought
on the world on football,
but now I have, which is,
oh right, football's just
like everything I believe in.
I don't care that you went to Harvard
and you're good at sales,
if you're a piece of shit,
you're not gonna be good at my company
'cause you're gonna destroy
everything around you.
That's football.
I don't give a fuck if you run a 39 40,
if you're beating women,
if you fucking hang out with
fucking p;ieces of shit,
if you're an insecure
dick in the locker room
and nobody likes you,
I don't care how many fucking
touchdowns you're gonna score.
Inevitably, that is going to be a problem.
So, that's what we need to do
with social media influencers
or anybody else.
I believe over time,
we will get far more thoughtful
around emotional intelligence
and I do believe that,
look, I think I'm the living proof of it,
my level of fame, whatever
it is, is growing rapidly.
It is not because I'm so attractive
or so funny or so
incredible in my athletics.
I am bringing value to human beings,
which results in admiration.
There are really fancy people
that I have dinners with,
handlers at events
that handle way more famous people than me
and they are constantly taken aback
by the interactions I have
with people who stop me in the halls,
at the airport, in life,
to the point where somewhere inevitable
by the third interaction,
if I take three selfies
or have two conversations,
they will literally,
and again, these are people
who are surrounded by the most
famous people in the world,
they will look at me and
say, what's going on?
And I do not believe they're saying,
I didn't realize how many people knew you.
I think what they're saying is,
why does this feel different?
And I believe that
admiration feels different
than liking somebody for something vain.
And I believe that that
will be scored long term,
impact and how you make people feel
and like the quality
of what you're putting out into the world
will continue to rise.
- I think subconsciously
people know the truth.
It resonates with a
person when they hear it
and you're everywhere with that truth
that you so passionately believe in,
and it just resonates with the soul.
- I think that's right.
And that's why the other
thing that people ask me about
when I'm in, again,
I'm traveling enough
and doing enough events
that people inevitably will
be with me for the day,
the partners of the event or what have you
and they're completely flabbergasted
by the demo range.
A lot of people think my
audience is like young dudes
and then we'll be walking in the airport
or at the event
and a 73-year-old African-American
female will roll up
and a 55-year-old white guy
or Latino nine-year-old from TikTok.
The truth is universal.
- Okay, okay, so it is,
and that brings me to my next question.
It comes from Liv.
My sales manager's daughter
watches you on TikTok
and she heard that I was interviewing you
and she said to me the
other night at a party,
she's like--
- How old is she?
- Steph?
- 10.
- 10, she's 10.
She said, "Would you ask
Gary a question for me?"
And I said, "Sure, what is it?"
So she had two questions.
One, why do you make videos
and two, what is your favorite food?
- I love it.
- [David] Right.
- This growth in the under 12 demo
is gonna be a lot of fun.
You get a lot of favorite food,
favorite food is definitely English peas.
So not snap peas,
not green beans,
there's something called English peas.
They are my complete obsession.
I love them.
When they're in season,
I'm like the happiest boy.
Why do I make videos?
- [David] Yes.
- I have an inherent want
to share goodness that I
feel uncomfortably grateful
and almost borderline guilty
in having in my body.
I used to hear things like, I have to,
or my body's making me
and I would always laugh
and think that was such horseshit,
like from a musician
or an actor or actress,
and I understand now.
I had no interest in
anything remotely close
to notoriety or fame.
I was 34 years old before I,
excuse me, I was 31 years old
before I made a wine video
and I was 34 years old before
I made a business video.
I didn't move to LA and wait tables
to be on television.
I worked in a liquor store in New Jersey.
- And that's where you did the video
was in a liquor store?
- Yeah, I mean and this
is where I do mine now.
It's not super complicated.
The world changed and gave
me opportunity to communicate
and Liv, I needed to
do it, I had to do it,
it felt right.
What I was doing for my inner circle
and for my acquaintances,
I now had an opportunity to do at scale
and the admiration is intoxicating.
The attention is cool, I'm okay with it
but I'm not in love,
if I was in need of the attention,
I would've gone for fame as a child.
The admiration is intoxicating.
I genuinely enjoy being admired
and I don't even know if that's like good
or like kind of like super weirdly selfish
and kind of like narcissistic.
I don't think so
but punchline is I'm okay saying,
I've never really heard anybody say it
so I almost don't know where
it sits when people hear me say
I'm addicted to admiration.
I see it as good.
It means I'm being held accountable
to doing good things
because I can't be admired
for making the most money.
- As long as you don't get high on it.
As long as it doesn't--
- I've gotten more sober on it.
As I continue to gain momentum,
I find myself going the other way.
I find myself trying to
scrutinize myself more.
I find myself trying to share more
of my shortcomings or inabilities.
I find myself overreacting
to making sure I say hello to everybody
or be thoughtful of
utterly every interaction.
I find myself speaking
to myself more saying,
fuck are you?
Do you understand that
you could die in an hour
and nobody's gonna give a fuck in a week
outside of like seven to
12 of your family members
and then your inner circle a little bit,
maybe you get a month
out of them but what?
The amount of times I say to myself,
who the fuck are you?
Do you understand that
if you died right now
nobody's gonna give a fuck is very high.
And I love that.
I don't think that's dark.
I think that's a counterbalance
conversation with myself
that is reacting to there's a lot going on
with me right now
and I'm aware of it
but I don't think that makes me special.
I really don't.
I think it makes my parents special.
I think it makes my circumstance special.
I feel like I'm a FedEx box,
I'm just a thing that's delivering it.
I'm just the container, really, mean it.
VaynerMedia's success I feel good about.
I'm the architect.
But I feel like I'm the product,
I'm the Pinocchio, I was made.
And so it's hard for me
when they're like, you're great,
I'm like fuck man, I wish I made me
instead of being me.
That's why, actually this is funny,
that's why me Gary Vaynerchuk,
the human strategist
is much more proud about
what's happening with me
than the person that gets the,
me behind me as I think
about how and what I do,
'cause I set the strategy,
that I'm actually really proud of,
not that people are
like, you're so awesome.
- Right, so if you're
coming from that place,
I ask everybody to leave our audience
with one successful mind tip.
Given that you feel like
you're just a channel for that,
that your parents made you
what would you recommend
to everybody that's listening
is something that they could
do from a thinking perspective?
- Practical optimism.
- [David] Practical optimism.
- It's pulling from the
opposite directions.
This is why left and right in America
are getting torn apart,
they're both right in different ways.
There is absolutely no room
for being cruel or mean or suppressive
to another human being, period.
There's also a very dangerous slope
when you eliminate merit
and accountability.
It leads to entitlement and delusion,
which leads to depression.
So fuck your eighth
place trophies, Brooklyn,
but fuck you if you're fucking,
you think you're better than somebody
because they don't look like you.
You're not from here, fuck you.
No cruelty and no delusional,
practical optimism.
You don't work,
it's highly likely the
thing you want to happen
will not happen.
But be optimistic.
Optimism really matters.
The internet is the playground,
not the government, not America,
not your parents, not
schools, not your job.
We all have unlimited,
we have levels of freedom
that have never been seen before.
You can create an avatar character,
if you think you're so suppressed,
create a cartoon,
make an old white man
if he's got it so good.
By the way, that's another thing
that people need to understand,
the level of depression in white males
is just as high as everybody else.
Privilege is mindset,
not what you look like.
The mindset game,
and we can see what we all look like,
and so we can make
judgment and that's fine,
I'm not gonna be able to change that.
But if you want to have a
more thoughtful conversation,
what's going on in people's
chemicals in their brain
is far more privilege than anything else.
There are people making $32,000 a year,
are a super minority of
minorities within this country
and are fucking skipping and whistling
to happiness every day.
And there's fucking a
41-year-old white dude
with a fucking Benzo and a
Ferrari and a Lamborghini
and a private plane and
making 33 million a year
who's fucking doing drugs at night
just to cope with the deep
inherent pain in his heart.
That's the truth.
- That's true.
- And so we got a lot of work to do
but I always think that times like this
lead to the bounce back.
I think we're on the verge
of a tremendous era in our society
that is going to be the reaction
to a lot of what's going on right now,
all the tension in the air,
and I'm looking forward to that,
I'm looking forward to in
my mid-'50s through '60s
to watch our society prosper
in its real efforts to do more
of the right collective thing
and I think that will only happen
once we have empathy
and compassion to listen
instead of just yelling
at each other and judging
and everyone sucks.
- Awesome.
Gary, thanks so much for doing this.
Really appreciate it.
- [Gary] My pleasure.
- Thanks.
(upbeat music)